Hi, my name is Gregory and today I'm
going to be talking about the voice
first AI overlay designing
conversational
co-pilots. So conversation is the oldest
interface. You can think of voice as our
original
API. It's the modality that we mastered
even before fire.
But when you're actually talking to
someone in live interaction, AI can't
really help. It's essentially locked out
of the conversation.
So this talk really was just a way to
explore this question which is as AI
systems grow more
powerful, can we find ways of keeping
humans in the loop with that progress
and on track with that
progress through what is our most
natural interface, the interface of
voice. There's a few reasons that this
seems like it's on the horizon.
The first is that we are developing
highly specialized agents that can
perform these incredible tasks over
longer and longer time
horizons. And we also have the entire
voice AI wave where we have
conversational agents that make AI very
accessible. You can have a call with a
conversational voice AI. It has access
to tools. It can search for something.
It can come back to you with that
information.
So we have those two explosions ongoing,
but it seems like the user experience
for ambient agents that respond not to a
text chat or to a message, but rather to
an event uh is still being defined. So
there's a great talk on this by uh
Harrison Chase uh last month called
ambient agents and the new agent
interface. And this talk is just a way
of exploring uh what might be some
future options
there. So there are currently these two
waves ongoing. The first is the agent
capability wave. Uh agents are getting
more powerful over time. We have better
ways of designing rag systems,
multi-step tool calling, uh acting over
longer and longer time horizons. There's
also this entire agent orchestration
uh piece to it as well. And then there's
the voice technology wave. So time to
first token is reducing
uh latency has improved a lot and it
also looks like full duplex speechtoech
models are on the horizon. So if we try
and combine these two, is there a way of
offering real time assistance via agents
but in an ambient setting,
conversational
setting? So there's a demo which is real
time conversational assistance in the
context of a live foreign language call
in the case where you do not necessarily
speak the language fluently. And what
you'll see in the demo is caption
scraping, smart
debouncing, managing the context so that
the suggestions, foreign language
suggestions that the LM is giving are uh
in line with what's happening in the in
the call.
uh there's an entire LM pipeline around
that around suggestion endpoint
translation endpoint and all of this
comes together within this voice first
AI overlay which is then
rendered
Uh, all female.
Temple
Park of
magazine. Yeah. Temple failed.
Yeah.
Um skateboard.
[Music]
So I'll just define the overlay
paradigm.
A voice first AI overlay sits
alongside humanto human calls and adds
real-time assistance into that call but
without becoming a third speaker. So it
is native to voice in that these two
speakers are of course speaking with
each other but it does not try to
actually participate in the call itself
by having a sort of group setting. So
the typical voice AI interaction is you
have a human speaking with an AI. That
AI can then have access to tools. It can
look up some information, get back to
you. But the overlay paradigm is
different. You have a human and a human
speaking with each other and an AI
operating in between to enhance and
augment the dialogue. So in the case of
the demo, the overlay is listening
passively to the natural dialogue and
then is surfacing relevant help under a
specific context. uh in that call. So
language suggestions, phrase
suggestions, definitions, things like
that. And otherwise it stays out of the
way until it is needed. So you can think
of it like overlay enables an ambient
agent but that is conversationally aware
because it exists only within that
conversational
moment. Where would overlays fit in? So
there are many layers uh of the stack
and and in the landscape. Currently we
have core speech models
uh to go from you know speech
recognition, text to speech. We have uh
intent and agent framework. So agent
orchestration for example the overlay
wouldn't necessarily uh be the agent
itself but it can decide when and where
an agent surfaces or whether help from
an agent surfaces. doesn't necessarily
need to be concerned with the internals
of that agent. There also meeting bots
or notetakers, but these happen after
the fact. They don't really happen in
flow during a live
interaction. There are voice avatars and
full AI callers, which is uh a very
interesting field right now. Um but with
overlays, it's not that they participate
in the dialogue directly. They simply
try to give a way of amplifying the
humans that are in the room. And part of
that is in order to do that there needs
to be UX research on cognitive load,
overlay design, timing, and this whole
intersection of human computer
interaction plus AI UX
research. Besides the design challenges,
there are also engineering challenges to
be aware of. So with normal voice AI
systems,
uh, latency is the most important thing.
But with overlays, it's a little bit
different because you're not constrained
necessarily by, uh, you know, a voice
agent getting back to you within a 200
to 400 millisecond window where it will
feel off if it's 400 milliseconds too
late. The thing is though, if an overlay
is assisting a live conversation and
that help comes early, it's an
interruption. it will interrupt the
conversation. If it comes late,
then you've missed the opportunity for
the help to be of highest value. So,
it's
useless. If the help arrives, but it's
loaded with the wrong context, then it's
kind of spam.
And even if all of that goes correctly,
uh if that help arrives but derails the
ongoing conversation, then it's not
usable because it hasn't really
respected the conversational flow, the
conversational rhythm of the two people
who are speaking with each other. And
through all of that, the latency still
has to be well managed throughout.
So if I could summarize it, it's timing,
relevance, attention and
latency. Now for this design landscape,
there's some principles that we can
think about. Say the first is that for
any overlay, we need to provide
transparency and control. So you should
be able to decide how much the overlay
is actually uh getting involved in the
conversation.
It should enforce minimum cognitive
load. So it could be the most
intelligent uh system in the world. But
if
it's entering the conversation in such a
way that it overloads the speakers and
derails their their conversation, then I
think um that's that's difficult. I
don't think it would be very usable in
this case. And the third is an
interesting one which is allowing
progressive autonomy. So in some cases,
you know, if you're new to a field or
something, you need a lot of help at the
beginning, but over time, you also want
to moderate how much help you're getting
so that you can also make sure that you
are uh learning in the right way. So
finding ways to allow progressive
autonomy, I think, is a key design
principle.
If you try to build one of these
systems, uh, you will almost certainly
encounter these four challenges. So,
I've listed them here as the four
horsemen of overlay engineering. The
first is jitterbug input. So, when
someone is speaking, they might pause to
take a breath uh, and there'll be a a
moment where the speech to text is no
longer running. So, yeah, debouncing is
quite important there. Context repair is
also very important. If you aim to give
live assistance, then you're probably
working with a sub-second speed limit.
So the entire pipeline has to be
optimized. The third is when help
arrives, it could come too early, so
premature interrupt or it could come uh
way too late or not at all. So no show.
And the way to try and think about that
is if you have very good conversational
awareness, you know at what point uh it
is the right time to step in and and
help. The fourth is glancible ghost. So
you can think of it like attention is a
kind of currency and every time uh a
hint arrives it taxes the attention of
the person that's seeing it. So it
shouldn't be for example if it's an
overlay in a video call like you know
completely obstructing the field of view
needs to be flexible needs to be
dismissible there's a lot of stuff
around uh user user interfaces that uh
can be helpful
here what excites me about the space so
I would say that I find it really
exciting that latency is now within
striking distance we can thread
roundtrip calls to a fastprovisioned LM
provider um in yeah 500 700 milliseconds
time to first token is very low in some
cases I've seen people get uh yeah very
very quick uh responses
back another angle is how to make the
entire thing private by design so we're
seeing models become increasingly
capable even though they're smaller uh
if you do run this entirely on device
how would that work you know how can we
make sure that we can get the same level
of intelligence but keep it private by
default on device inference. I think
that's an interesting angle. The third
is how to inject a strong user
experience ethos into the entire
concept. So a UX dance that
values human conversation
uh and and really respects it like it's
something that is very native to human
beings and yeah in many ways kind of
something that should be
protected and I think the fourth angle
is um more speculative but voice as a
linkable surface.
So if you have uh ambient agents in the
context of calls or or or uh live live
human
conversations, can they be linked in
some way? How would you orchestrate
that? I think that's an interesting uh
piece where I'm curious.
So one thing that I'm curious about is
that ASR errors can cascade.
So, uh, if you have a word error rate of
5% and in some of those cases you
transcribe don't to do, for example, so
I do want this versus I don't want this.
Uh, the overlay might give the wrong
advice. So, how to how to deal with
that? Um, pairing it with the amount of
conversational context that you have
would be one way. But yeah, this is
something that I'm quite curious about
how to how to think about. Another thing
is proity and timing complexity.
So because we've had voice for so long
and we've really evolved with with voice
uh we are hardwired to detect even micro
intonation signals and those are all
lost when we just convert straight from
speech to text. So I think that's also
something that I'm wondering about how
much what is the quantity of that
information loss and can you still get
relevant assistance even if everything
is flattened from speech to to text and
then of course the security surface. So
if you have agents actually interacting
in live conversations,
um what security risks does that pose?
It it feels like a completely new
security surface to think about and uh
yeah it would be interesting to look
into that further as
well. Extensions and future directions
for voice first overlays. So one is um
it does look like full duplex speech
models are on the horizon where you do
not convert from speech to text in order
to do anything. You take just the raw
audio through a speech model. It's not
get converted to text. You have audio
features. Can you provide contextual
suggestions in an overlay paradigm just
with that? I think that's interesting.
Another thing is multimodal
understanding. So being able to see the
live call or the live video uh might
give information that makes the AI
interaction more helpful. And then
speculative execution and and caching
that's also quite
interesting. So yeah, I think overall uh
it's a very interesting space to be in
and I think in many ways just with how
voice AI has exploded, it does seem like
the future is conversational.
Seems like the technology is ready but
the interfaces are
not. And uh yeah, thanks for listening.
I've dropped my email there. Thanks.